absolute maximum absolute minimum also
sometimes referred to as global maximum
or minimum what are we talking about
we're in calculus land which enables us
to find stationary points stationary
points are often but not always turning
points yeah so you've got a concave down
turning point which would be a maximum
you've got a concave up turning point
which would be a minimum okay but one of
the things we have noticed is that we
need differentiate when you find your
turning point yeah it's a maximum or a
minimum acquaintance to the stuff around
it right according to what's nearby
what's in the neighborhood but it may
not be the actual full-on maximum or
minimum and here's a good example right
have a look at this function okay now
you don't necessarily need to know what
it's going to look like but you've got
some rough ideas of the kind of shape
it's going to have right you can see at
the front here this X to the 4 it's in
the driver's seat right whatever has the
highest power is what takes over okay so
because it's got X to the 4 that's an
even power so what happens when you put
negative numbers in to an even power
they've become positive and of course if
you put positive numbers into an even
power also positive so what that means
is at extreme values big negative values
big positive values you're going to have
positive everything's going to be up
right in addition to that bless you you
can see that there's no there's no minus
sign to make it concave down sort of so
it's this nice continuous curve no holes
no no denominator or anything like that
so we're gonna find some maximums and
some minimums but you can't say that one
of those stationary points like that for
instance
you're going to find a concave down
stationary point but that's not the
maximum because you could go you just go
a bit further and you'll go higher right
so if we want the absolute maximum or
the the global maximum on a curve like
this we actually need to restrict the
domain and we can restrict it however we
like but just as some example values
because I pinch these from from your
textbook
sothank example values would be this
okay so if we restrict our domain to
this little area then we can say all
right well the graph stops somewhere so
I can say there's the maximum right so
how are we gonna work out where the
Maxima minima are well first let's look
for these stationary points let's look
for these guys because they're very
likely will give us some good
information
okay so let's differentiate this is not
hard to differentiate what's our first
term gonna be forest cubes this guy's
going to turn into take away 16x and of
course that constant term drops off so
no problem so this is our first
derivative which I'm going to factorize
why am i instinctively going to
factorize I'm try to play stationary
points right which are hopefully going
to be turning points as well well they
will exist where this guy is equal to 0
and that's easiest to find when I'm
factorized okay so let's do that common
factor of 4x so ad that comes you can
see that what's left behind is that's an
x squared takeaway for so I can go a bit
further now can tire that 4x is just
gonna hang out the front and that leaves
you with X minus 2 X plus 2 okay
great so just before we leave off this
how many stationary points you expecting
out of this you're expecting three
because look you started with degree
four if you've got a polynomial like
this every time you differentiate every
subsequent time reduces the power by one
so we have a cubic and it's not that
surprising that it's got three
intercepts okay so therefore I have
stationary points at and now I've got my
three values right so they're very
convenient no you just like sir okay now
interestingly if our question was just
find the max find the minimum okay I
actually don't need to determine the
nature think about this for a second if
what I'm actually interested in is the
maximum value or the minimum
you if this is what the curve looked
like right then suppose this is negative
2 this is 0 and this is 2
horizontally speaking okay do you see
I mean I'm gonna find out there's a
minimum I'm gonna find out there's a
maximum but that doesn't actually answer
the question the minimum would be what's
the actual Y value down here like maybe
it's negative 3 or something like that
that's how far down it goes okay that's
the actual airtime that's the minimum
value of the function so it doesn't
actually matter to me I don't have to
determine their nature and go through
some additional tests why don't you to
find out is where is it where is it I'm
just going to go straight to coordinates
remember a big flow chart a huge
enormous flow chart you've got two
hearts to it right the bottom half the
big complicated part is is the second
derivative of the first derivative
determine the nature but I need to find
these things that's the top half right I
just need to put these guys into the
function okay so what I'm gonna do is
let's draw up a table values like so but
we're gonna draw it a little wider than
you might think
okay I'm gonna have two rows one's gonna
be for these X values and the other
one's going to be for Y values okay so
I'm not determining nature here I'm just
going to see where these points are and
that will tell me what's high and what's
low okay now the reason why it's so wide
is because along with these three
stationary points I'm going to test the
endpoints right cuz see here's my graph
right here's my guy so suppose this
ending here negative 4 right
maybe my negative 4 is here okay so that
endpoint there I need to find out where
that is because if it's higher it might
be more of a maximum than this or if
this guy over here is the maximum so
where these values are is going to tell
me where this is going to be useful
information or not so therefore got
three stationary points I've got two end
points so let's divide this thing up so
one two three here my endpoints since
they're on the ends I'm gonna put them
at the start and at the end and I notice
actually I
even need I've done an extra spot
because do you notice since my endpoint
here is one I've actually eliminated out
one of the stationary points I found did
you notice that so this is outside the
domain this guy so in fact I didn't even
need this row I'm gonna drop that off
okay so there is a stationary point at -
but it's not relevant to this domain so
not relevant let's put in the stationary
points that are relevant negative 2 and
0 that's a messy fall ok so now I just
need to find some Y values I'll give you
a second this is just some calculator
work key go ahead crunch some numbers
and then find out some coordinates for
me you do that
okay someone got some values for me for
the first coordinate X negative 4y is
equal to 139 okay
I'm guessing this might be one of our
answers for negative 2 minus 5 for 0
that's just going to be 11 and 4x equals
1/4 fantastic okay
so here if you wanted to you could label
these this is an endpoint this is a
stationary point this is a stationary
point this is an endpoint can you see I
don't care about like nature or anything
like that
I just can care about what's a big
number but what's a small number right
so you can clearly see the maximum which
is the maximum in this domain the
maximum is 139 that's all you have to
say right you would say 4x equals
negative 4 1 2 3 4 let's call that 139
up there so it's going to go from there
and it's going to screech all the way
down to negative 5 like that they need
it for maybe so it's gonna come straight
down it's gonna turn here cuz that's a
stationary point and then he gets to 0
11 I've had some hundred there you know
where's 11 gonna be I don't know
somewhere pretty close down here like
that
and then x equals 1 which would be there
it goes down a little more so this looks
like the shape there you go you get the
idea okay
so where's the maximum I can see it
right up there the maximum is and I
don't have to qualify it anymore it's
the maximum the maximum is y equals
hydrogen 39 so this is not where the
maximum occurs which is negative 4 but
it is the maximum itself and the minimum
is this only one that's negative okay
that are finished so the reason why we
care about these things is because in
real life situations where functions
exist often there is this domain sort of
imposed on it from the outside like this
function can go anywhere but
actual values that we're interested in
that only exist in this little spot here
okay